now some of you know I was in the
hospital September October for three
weeks and I had an infection in my left
leg which comes every two or three years
I've had three times now and it's pretty
nasty stuff when I was in there the
doctors at beginning the reason I was
there three weeks is they couldn't
figure it out they tried a total of
three different antibiotics the first
one didn't work the second one worked
more or less than the third when finally
killed it
and so during that time I didn't think I
was coming out or I had a lot of doubts
with her whether the doctors were gonna
get me out of there you know and it
turns out that I had been writing a book
for two years and I wanted to call it
the Rope hypothesis I was writing that
book on and off over two years and here
I we had a powwow with my son and with
my niece who came to visit me at the
hospital we had this we were around the
campfire so to speak and I was telling
them you know it was a shame that I
didn't get to write that book that if I
happen to not come out of here you know
that book would never have been written
and it gave me a few ideas we kicked
around some ideas and they are younger
than me so they came up with some new
proposals and I listened to them and the
first thing I did was Chuck my two years
of work down the drain I threw it away
completely I don't even know where I
probably have the file somewhere but I
got rid of all of it completely and
instead I began writing a new book based
on their suggestions and I wrote about
2/3 of the book by the time I got out of
the hospital fortunately after three
weeks I was able to get out of there and
since then it's been went for months and
we've been editing it with my son and
myself again one of my son's I've got
three boys and this is my youngest son
and we edit it and today I put it
finally online and to probably have this
week was we had problems with you know
you try to transfer a word to PDF files
they move your pictures around whenever
whoever has done that knows what I'm
talking about it's a pain in the butt
and we could get out the book out on
time that was the issue and I wanted to
surprise you on Wednesday first and that
didn't happen then I tried to do it for
Friday that didn't happen well we
finally figured it out and took time and
we fixed it and what's the issue the
issue is we tried to write the book so
that a baby can understand it so the
issue is trying to make it simple we
have to take a lot of stuff out that was
relevant but not not that critical and
so we try to write the book in such a
way that anyone can read it real quickly
with no understanding of physics at all
hey and it would give them an insight
what some of these invisible things out
there are you know what is light what is
electricity
what is magnets is what is gravity how
does he hadn´t work and first we have to
describe a little bit of what it does
what we're supposed to explain I know we
went in there and explained ok that's
essentially how I wrote the book and my
son helped me edit it and so we put it
online today and the book is free the
book is totally free it is downloadable
ok and we want everybody to download it
ok and here's the site let me show you
the site because I created a new website
ok and that's the website now ok it's
known as rope hypothesis calm and if you
go to the section known as book but a
book up there if you open that up you'll
find a book it's called the rope
hypothesis you can download the PDF file
it's hopefully very easy to read and
hopefully you'll like it
ok it's for people who really want to
get acquainted to a new way of looking
at the universe ok and what we plan to
do in the next or what I plan to do in
the next few weeks is translated to
different languages I'm personally gonna
translate it into Spanish which I'm very
familiar with and I'm gonna be
translating it using
or some other internet translator and
then I'm going to look for people who
can you who have a better mastery of the
tongue than what Google has writer or
whoever right and they're going to give
it a final version and I'm going to put
their names in lights if they do that
job right I'm gonna put them on a
website and on the honor roll and
hopefully we're gonna we're gonna
stimulate this through different cities
I'm gonna put ads in different cities
asking people telling people about the
book telling them that you can download
it and this way maybe we can spread the
Rope hypothesis around and again the
issue is because all Havanese are
blocked you can't publish anything in a
respectable journal because they're all
manned by people like Rennie and John
bys and they're never gonna allow some a
different theory qualitative
interpretation of the universe to be
published that's the issue and so we
have no other recourse but to go around
that and stimulate it or promoted in
different cities and through ads that's
what we're gonna be doing and so yeah
we're gonna be doing that that's one
thing the other thing I'm gonna be doing
probably starting in March because I
don't think I'll be able to get to it
until then
is I'm gonna open up a channel a Spanish
channel on Fridays and for those of you
who might know Spanish well you can tune
in there as well so I'm gonna go
stimulate a channel because what
happened was that some people from the
Flat Earth in South America they
challenged a lot of my theories there or
my arguments really not my theory
because I don't think they're familiar
with my theory but they challenged some
of the arguments and they did it like a
tune up to our video flat earthers and
so I'm gonna address those issues I'm
gonna be addressing those issues point
by point that's going to take the rest
of the year and that's what Spanish
channels going to be about and of course
if first I want to get the book in
Spanish and again make it free to the
world
and he went out there can just download
it okay and here let me show you the
site again okay first let me get my son
who was the editor and we have a way of
calling him and that's with my little
chicken and it calls rice so here's that
over there you know you need up over
here so people want to see you so this
is why this is my editor he's my boss
yeah ion's and uh maybe we get him
through one of the sights I cut up with
us here after yeah I did everything so
anyways here let me show you the site
again see if I can show you where they
find a book okay and so it's you go to
the rope hypothesis and you'll find
they're under books and you'll find the
rope hypothesis book in PDF format you
can download it send it your friends
family whoever okay it's available to
the world 160 page book heavily in
illustrated and with all the
explanations necessary okay and yeah we
do welcome feedback okay sure there's
gonna be a lot of that but again the
idea is to present a new theory a new
proposal so that you guess he to say you
can see the universe in a different way
it doesn't mean you have to believe it
it just means we're gonna be presenting
in that book a different version of how
the universe works you can take it or
leave it but at least you'll be exposed
to it right now nobody's allowed to be
exposed to it it's like you know these
people have decided that you're not
supposed to see any other theories I
mean I don't agree with the electric
universe but I think they have a right
to put their theory forward just like
anybody else and they've struggled over
the years you know and they're not the
only ones the John chapel's group which
I criticize the other day the same thing
they they try to put their stuff out
with the ether and so on doesn't mean
you have to believe in them but
certainly you want to be exposed to this
you know I went
I was in contact I studied Buddhism and
Hinduism and some of these other
religions you know I don't believe in in
any other stuff but you need to be
exposed to to other ideas and it makes
you think and why does your your
broadens your mind and these people are
not allowing that right now that's the
problem that's the big problem they're
not allowing a challenge to general
relativity or quantum mechanics
especially from a qualitative point of
view that's the big problem right now we
have a different interpretation for the
same equations that's the issue and
they're not going to allow that because
means that everything they did in the
last hundred years is wrong you know so
they don't want to expose the public to
new ideas and they're doing it with your
tax dollars
so think about that for a second good